you're playing with gravity
heat the strain point it's all such fun
[Music]
my name is tim dryer i'm a scientific
glassblower
i work in scientific glass all day and
when i
see the techniques that i'm using i
just thought to myself this would be the
coolest drinking vessel i've ever seen
why doesn't
anybody ever do that so
that's what we're doing today we're
taking borosilicate glass tubing
and blowing it into bar where reimagine
first i'm going to start by making the
cups
i start with a piece of 44 millimeter
tubing
i heat up a section
[Music]
i close the end off
i punty up the punty
is just an attachment that's going to be
removed at some point
it's made out of bore silicate rod
because i want it to stick to the bubble
that i want to help control
and then i blow and stretch and push and
pull
into the shape of the cup that i want
when i blow a cup i'm spinning both
hands
roughly at the same speed in the same
direction the same
lateral pressure there's a lot that goes
on when you start
getting a bubble soft
[Music]
okay so now i'm going to do a fire cut
where i'm going to heat just a real
thin band of glass pull it basically rip
it
open and this will be the top of the cup
[Music]
so now where this is tor there's gonna
be a little
blip that i need to pick off of there
see it right there that needs to come
off there otherwise it'll just amplify
as you
make the lip or the foot
then i heat the whole lip evenly and i
use my graphite paddle to push the rest
of the glass back
even and then my graphite rod to flare
the lip even
graphite is used in glass blowing
because it can take a lot of heat and
it's pretty much
indestructible when it comes to flames
there you have it
i can see that it's even it's square
and i usually pull it off on my punty
handle
with a small sharp flame in my tweezers
tweezers are extension of my fingers
when i'm working
i can't touch the glass so i use my
tweezers
so now i'm just closing off the end of
the tube i'm gonna
get rid of this raw end and close the
end of the tube i close off the end and
i peel off
what bad glass is on the end and then it
seals off the tube again so it allows me
to blow another bubble
i can work my way down a whole six foot
length of tube
that way
borosilicate tubing is soda lime glass
with boron added to it
it makes it a stronger harder glass in
flameworking we work with a torch
so it needs to be able to go from room
temperature into a 3000 degree flame
and other glasses can't do that that's
why
flame working is different than furnace
working
furnace working is where they take batch
glass
mix them in a big crucible add a bunch
of heat and
literally melt the glass and then they
go in with steel pipes
and dip it out of the furnace and shape
it and then put it right into an
annealing oven
so now i'm going to heat this little
section and i'm going to stretch it
if you take chopsticks and you put them
in a bowl of honey
and you roll it up and the thickness of
the honey builds a little ball on the
end
that's a lot what it feels like you're
dealing with a really thick liquid on
the end of a
tube or rod
now i'm going to blow this up and squash
it a little
i use quite a bit of heat 3 200 degrees
fahrenheit is the actual flame
temperature
the valves on the torch are the control
for propane and oxygen to give different
flame intensities and flame patterns
there's the focused
wide soft flame like when i blow a cup i
use
the outer fire to get more glass off so
i can blow a bigger bubble
and then there's a sharp pointed center
fire flame
they're both roughly the same as far as
heat wise
it's the volume of flame that it gives
i do not i have a fire extinguisher so i
gotta heat up a wide
section and then blow to shape the cup
when the flame is blue it is the
absolute hottest it can be because at
that point you're burning two parts
oxygen to one part gas
the sodium that's in the glass is what's
burning off that's the bright yellow you
see it's called the sodium flare
so the glass is actually giving some of
its life away
overworking the glass can cause
de-vitrification because you
burn all of the sodium out so you want
to try to work the glass
as little as possible so that you
maintain
the integrity and the chemical
properties in the glass that you need
to keep it clear
so now on this one i'm going to put a
flatter bottom here so i'm going to a
sharper fire and heat up just this
bottom
section and push a square shoulder
while i'm working i wear diedidium
glasses
they're made out of a material called
neodidium and they filter out the sodium
wavelength in the flame which is the
bright yellow
and it allows me to see into the wall
thickness
of the glass when i'm heating it
i wear a kevlar sleeve on my right arm
to protect me from the heat
if you have long sleeves on cotton could
potentially catch on fire so
i try not to catch myself on fire things
have gotten kind of cool down here on
the end so i want to make sure that
i'm not letting them get stone cold it's
a technique called flame annealing
i wanted to warm everything back up
roughly the same
temperature to help it equalize
i'm going to go to a fire cut another
fire cut
and i go to an overhand rotation instead
of
underhand because i'm pulling
when i'm just blowing a bubble i prefer
the underhand technique because i feel
i'm in more control
of the rotation when i do the fire cut i
need to keep things
even plain i have a lot more control in
that
respect when i'm overhand
the glass gets soft at around 1100
1200 degrees and you got to be careful
because you can boil the glass
where the surface of the glass will
literally start to boil you're getting
it so hot
so that's why the even rotation of the
glass is important
to get the even heat all the way around
if i was to just stand still
the glass would boil in that spot where
the torch was hitting in and it would
fall to the ground
right where the heat hits the tubing is
the hottest
so when i come out of the flame you'll
see me just let it
rotate i'm letting the heat equalize
because it'll have a hot spot and if i
start blowing right away it'll blow out
of
round and blow uneven
so you need to give the heat time to
equalize
in the tubing and then you blow very
slowly and that's the key to
blowing a good cup
all three cups are complete
next i'm going to make a foot for each
one of my cups
i make a foot by closing off the end
attaching my punty or my handle
and then i blow a small squatty bubble
a squatty bubble is a bubble that's just
basically compressed
to oblong shape
do a fire cut
i use the graphite rods and my graphite
paddle to
flare my foot to the flatness that i
want
[Music]
sometimes the foot has an uneven edge to
it
sometimes i go down on my graphite block
and it helps even that out so it makes
it so the cup isn't going to be rocky
and then i just pull it off the punty
[Music]
next we're going to wrap some coils
i'm using a smaller diameter tubing and
i'm wrapping it around
a graphite mandrel to give me the shape
and size that i want
you're feeding your tubing in over the
top of the mandrel
and everything comes together it is
almost magical because
the tubing is just soft enough cools
enough when it touches the mandrel
and it just happens all by itself
the graphite expands probably two to
three times
farther than the glass does so
as it cools it's going to shrink twice
as much
it will shrink down and allow the glass
to slide
off and now for the fun part
we're going to assemble the coil the
foot and the cup
all together
[Music]
i've sketched out what i want the cups
to look like
but this is where the tricky parts are
i'm cutting the coils to give me
sections
of workable size i cut the coils using a
tungsten carbide
blade a really hard metal so it
scratches the glass
and with pressure on the backside causes
the glass to break
in an even way
so now i'm just pulling a hole in the
ring because i need to be able to blow
this together
when i seal this end off and i take my
piece of
six millimeter and i seal that temporary
blow
pipe and then where i scratch cut it
it has carbide in there it'll leave a
dirty spot in the clear glass so i peel
that
little piece off and i heat the whole
thing
soften it so i can go on my graphite
flatten it
flat
so now i need to pick these edges
together carefully
stitch it up
the hand torch is extremely portable
it's a very condensed
small flame i use the hand torch for
small seals
doing a very concentrated small work
okay so that one i'm going to put on
there like
that so i'll bend it just a little bit
so now i need to do the same thing with
this one so i have a pair
ready to put this one together
the pleural stopper is just a big
stopper
and i use it as a holder with a handle
so i can put my cups
on it and hold them in the flame
and still be able to blow
i use a small hand torch to heat just a
very small
piece of the glass i blow a blister it
looks like a blister
and then i pop that open and then i'm
ready to seal on any kind of side
arm or connection
i'm still blowing while i'm attaching
things
so they don't constrict close because
when you seal the glass together
and heat it it wants to gather onto
itself or constrict
and the air pressure inside allows me to
blow
and flow that wall thickness even
from where i made my attach
i have to keep the cups and the feet in
the coil and everything
above 490 degrees which is the strain
point
if you fall below that is when things
can crack
so once i warm things up and get
everything hot i need to stay there
while i'm doing my seals
[Music]
my favorite part is the assembly no it
is i get in a trance and i can feel the
way the wall thickness i can't explain
it i love
every part of the assembly process
and i'm kind of that guy who's
pushing all the boundaries where i don't
really care what people think
or whether it's even practical or
whether you can ever use it again
it's just exciting for me
after i've worked it there'll be really
thin spots for on a cup
and then a real thick spot down by the
stem because the glass is
cooling at different rates when it's
thick and thin
i need to go in the oven with it now
when you put things in the annealing
oven they heat up
all the molecules evenly and it cools
them all back down so it heats up 565
degrees centigrade
and hold it for around 15 to 20 minutes
to allow everything to equalize
and then you can cool back down through
the 490
temperature range the strain point my
annealing oven
that process usually takes about an hour
hour and a half
to get up to temperature and then about
another two or three hours to cool down
depending on your oven if you have a
brick oven it will hold the heat longer
if you have a
fiber frax oven it will cool a lot
faster i have one that's fire brick so
it holds the heat longer and it's more
of a ramp down cooling versus a
shelf drop off cooling
you have scientific glass which is
used in research chemistry but yet
nobody's ever brought that same material
into a bar glassware
decanter type of scene you have very
distinctive lines between
the glass you see in a bar and the glass
you see in a research lab
why can't it all be together